foreign
as tanks rolled into Ukraine Russians
were left with a stark choice
continue as normal or make a stand
against Putin's War
e
is
[Music]
but speaking out in Russia is almost
impossible
um
for the past year The Economist has
followed some of the Russians brave
enough to tell the truth about the
conflict
um
but when even the smallest Act of
rebellion can have terrible consequences
and running away is an act of defiance
foreign what real hope is there
is
very hard to imagine this War ending
without some form of violence being
brought back inside Russia
[Music]
foreign
Putin Was preparing for war she feared
the worst
news
foreign
ER has spent years trying to curb his
power as part of the opposition but the
events of 2022 would be the greatest
challenge yet
foreign
[Music]
Russia has invaded Ukraine explosions
and arid Sirens ringing out here in Kiev
Russian missiles have blasted air bases
and other military assets we are
witnessing history the largest war in
Europe since the end of World War II
on the morning of the invasion Marina
moves fast making one of the first
direct calls for anti-war protests is
her call hits a nerve thousands of
ordinary Russians take to the streets
but the police are waiting
peaceful protests will not be tolerated
by that time the police is completely in
control Putin knew what he was doing he
was he has been preparing for it the
most important thing for Putin at that
point is to show that there is no
protest to show that people are isolated
Marina never made it to the rally she
had called for
foreign
given Russia's scale the protests are
relatively small but the police
Crackdown is decisive 15
000 are arrested in the first month of
the war across 155 cities even those
just trying to document the protests can
be targeted
photojournalist vika is covering the
rallies
is
10 days after the invasion the police
sees her
yes
to provide
the Crackdown does not stop at arresting
reporters
determined to silence old Ascent Putin
passes new laws which make it a crime to
criticize the war even calling it a war
and not a special military operation can
land you in prison
do you have this predominant feeling of
shock and anger there is no way of
demonstrating it not through media not
through protest it's a point at which
the regime turns from authoritarianism
into complete tyranny
the effect is immediate TV stations walk
out in protest
250 media channels are blocked and by
the end of the year more than 500
journalists leave Russia
while it might appear this repression
came from nowhere the war against the
resistance within Russia began long
before the invasion
investigative journalist Raman
dobrahordov runs the website The Insider
our investigations were mostly data
driven we were using open source
intelligence we debunked some
disinformation of the Russian propaganda
which is very very toxic
he fled Russia after the FSB raided his
home in 2021
he was just one of many journalists and
activists forced out or into prison in
preparation for war
Putin understood that like he can't wage
war into France so she needs to do
something with the Russian opposition
Russian media inside the country first
Putin has been preparing for this war
since probably 2014. since the
annexation of Crimea by purging Russian
information Space by purging Russian
politics of any descending voices and
now
looking back at it you realize that the
poisoning of Alexander navalny was all
part of this operation
when war broke out opposition leader
Alexi navalny had already been in jail
for over a year
and as the conflict continued he could
only denounce the war from his cell
s
so the war is on two fronts the wars in
Ukraine but the war is also inside
Russia
since being forced out of Russia exiled
journalists like Rahman have become a
crucial part of the resistance
with far more power to undermine the
Kremlin than they would have inside the
country
our audience is bigger despite all the
censorship people feel angry about the
situation with unpredictability over the
future and we feel that they trust our
information more and more because they
see that the propaganda is deceiving
them
so that's why we're so invested in
working as journalists now because we
feel that it is a moment in the 20 years
after we live under Putin that
everything can change
for russia-based journalists that change
feels distant
reporting is almost impossible
yes
foreign
after the police Crackdown the rallies
subside within two weeks but the news
from Ukraine is horrific
Russian troops have massacred civilians
in towns outside Kiev
this is
There is almost no way to protest
against these crimes in Russia
those who speak out face years in jail
and instead of rallies activists now
stage one-man pickets or individual
rebellions like changing Supermarket
price tags for anti-war slogans
but even reporting on these acts is
incredibly dangerous
is
um
that individual action really matters
because what this people are saying is
we have agency this war will not be
carried out in our name and yes at the
moment they seem like a molecule in this
kind of sea of conformism and this
individual
bravery still matters
but outside Russia individuals who fight
back have far more power
together
[Music]
Maria alohina or Masha is part of
feminist protest group [__] Riot she
was under strict police curfew when war
broke out but managed to escape her
building disguised as a food delivery
driver and flee the country
[Music]
no stranger to persecution she was
famously locked up after performing in a
cathedral in Moscow in 2012.
but she believes State repression is now
far worse
just
because
currently touring Europe with their
protest song she enjoys Free Speech no
longer possible in Russia
[Music]
is
thank you so much
[Applause]
but protest songs would be no match for
Putin's next move
hi I'm Arcadia strovsky I'm The
Economist Russia editor if you'd like to
read more about our coverage of Russia
Ukraine and the war why not subscribe to
The Economist you will receive weekly
analysis of global Affairs which you can
read on your app online or listen to our
audio Edition for the best offer click
on the link
Russian President Vladimir Putin says he
has signed a decree ordering the partial
military mobilization of Russia's Armed
Forces beginning today
from September ordinary men are
conscripted to join the war
tearing families apart
um
there is a violent surge of anger
conscription offices are set on fire
and for the first time in months crowds
take to the streets
vika had planned to cover the rallies
but on the morning of the protest her
flat was raided by Security Services
her door was smashed open
across
video
and her equipment confiscated
um
there is no rule logic to how loud you
need to speak against the war
to get picked up so the point is control
the point of sphere
yeah
at the spices
and shed so
um
[Music]
for the men being told to fight and die
for Putin waiting is not an option the
only way they can resist is to flee
we've eaten potatoes New Bright
activities
[Music]
over three quarters of a million people
leave in the month after mobilization
it worker costia documents his journey
on social media
um
foreign
[Music]
but this Exodus plays into Putin's hand
The Evil Genius of this mobilization was
that Putin cap the borders open he
allowed people to leave the country
while mobilizing others
you let those who have resources the
skills and agency to leave the country
at the same time you're recruiting
people who don't have that agency who
feel they have no choice but to go and
fight
in Armenia the ark a charity set up to
help Russians fleeing persecution is
inundated with requests for help
Dimitri is among the new arrivals
he left home 10 days ago
information
foreign
he escaped without a plan for his future
leaving his fiancee behind in Russia
is
[Music]
Channel
um
spawn
[Music]
after immobilization the need for
protest is even more urgent social media
sites are flooded with men claiming to
be conscripts
it is becoming clear the conscripts are
not properly trained or armed
and yet Putin's position is stronger
than before conscription started
a lot of people before the mobilization
started believe Putin will not be able
to get over this line that this will
erode support for the regime and this
would be a turning point
Putin has proved them wrong yes these
are not the best equipped or the best
trained troops but in the eyes of a
large portion of Russian population
Putin still has legitimacy if the Tsar
tells you to go and fight and die in the
war people go and fight and die in that
war
there are no accurate figures for how
many Russians have been killed
when mobilization was announced the
government said just under 6 000 had
died
but unofficial estimates put it closer
to one hundred thousand
is
in the absence of reliable numbers
Marina has started to build a database
of the Dead
but questioning the official narrative
about the war is a dangerous Act of
resistance
[Music]
today one of Marina's contacts in
southern Russia is hunting graveyards in
search of the true number of dead
it's dangerous work they've already been
stopped by police several times
[Music]
and cataloging the cost of war is taking
its toll on Marina
um
foreign
but despite the dangers of speaking the
truth in Russia vika and Marina will not
leave
foreign
[Music]
a year after the invasion it is becoming
clear that change in Russia may not be
brought about by activists in the
country but by losses in Ukraine
the most dangerous for Putin is when the
perception of his position changes on
the battlefield if the Russians start
feeling that he has actually lost the
War I think political situation Russia
could change very very fast
until that day activists can only hope
their efforts will make a difference to
how history remembers Putin's Ward
foreign
[Music]
I write about Russia in Ukraine for The
Economist if you want to read more of
our coverage of Ukraine or Russia in the
war please click on the link below and
don't forget to subscribe